hi
are we ready
hi i'm ann gibbons and welcome to
science live chat
uh we're here today to talk about a
thousand years of health and disease uh
and death and that's brought to you by
science magazine i'm here today with
clark spencer larson who's a biological
anthropologist at ohio state university
and with hendrick corner
bless you a paleogeneticist who is here
who studies ancient dna from mcmaster
university in hamilton canada
and uh
i think viewers you can ask questions by
posting comments at the bottom of this
page of our live chat page so scroll
down to the bottom and you can post a
question i will be looking through those
questions and asking them so i think one
of the first questions let's go ahead
and start okay are you guys ready
let's go for it okay so bianca asks a
good question what are the diseases that
you want to study at this site at this
medieval site body of possibility in
tuscany italy
and let's start with you clark and then
let's have you answer that hendrick
after him
okay so
mainly
we're interested in
chronic infectious diseases and
some non-infectious diseases
and we're interested in chronic diseases
because those are diseases that last
the individual has to live long enough
to express the bone changes uh
for example tuberculosis
people have that for years and years and
so we see changes taking place there we
want to see if there's leprosy
that's a possibility we want to see if
there's a
treponemal disease which could be
both venereal or non-venereal forms of
syphilis
we're very interested in
oral health
and the indicators of oral health are
dental caries and
and periodontitis
we're also interested in in metabolic
disorders that might appear in these
populations
including
vitamin deficiencies we can detect some
of those in bone
iron deficiency anemia we can detect
growth arrests easily seen in teeth
and one of my favorites is
osteoarthritis
which is a
disease caused by wear and tear
on the joints of the skeleton
so those are some of the the big ones
we're looking for
and before i get to hendrick how can you
see them in the bones or the teeth other
than
cavities which you mentioned how do you
see a key be in a bone or how do you see
a vitamin deficiency yeah let me i just
happen to have
some bones here
so here's a
as i mentioned one of my favorites is
osteoarthritis
and this is a femur or thigh bone
um
and this is uh the hip area of the bone
right here where the head of the femur
articulates with a pelvis
and if you look at this you can see a
whole bunch of bone that's been
build up
around the head of the femur
this bone
there's a
a femur without osteoarthritis so we're
looking at these big disparities here
between um
between these skeletons
we can also
look at dental caries by
simply looking at the surfaces of the
teeth see if i can hold this up
and this is not from italy but uh it's
an anatomical uh skull so we look for
pits and grooves and teeth caused by
tooth decay
so those are some examples of
the kinds of things we're looking for
we're looking at the vertebral column
such as this one here this is also
non-archaeological but
we look for evidence of tb where
the bone has literally been destroyed
by the bacterium uh
and so that's a another indicator that
we hope to see
in fact we have seen some evidence of
this
uh in the series
what diseases are you most interested in
finding at this thousand-year-old site
from medieval ages up to the 19th
century
and then how do you detect them with dna
yeah yeah so we do you obviously we use
a very different method of detection
we're looking for
uh the small molecular signatures
whether they be dna in some cases you
may have lipids some people believe you
can look for lipids of tuberculosis for
example is an indication of presence i
think uh some of them were very
interested in some some similar to the
ones that clark mentioned so chronic
infectious diseases obviously
tuberculosis
we've had a passion recently for pestis
yersinio pestis the causative agent in
the case of black death and so we're
very interested in tracking that over
space and time so we would hope to find
those at the early medieval and then
subsequent later uh dated
samples from this particular site
cholera we're interested in obviously
the protozoan parasitic infections of
malaria that's still very big open
question about whether malaria was
present in the uh in italy at this time
point uh across this time or whether or
not it was really so relegated still to
the south uh in parts of africa
um and i think one of the great things
about well the potential i should say is
the possibility for looking at
co-infections so not just strictly
looking at a particular pathogen uh but
to look at sort of the entire uh
pathogenic microbiome so how are these
people burdened over sort of space and
time
uh and what does that give us does it
you know give us a better appreciation
for human health over time uh and of
course you know what we use are small
short dna fragments
uh and that could be problematic uh in
some cases to identify because the
fragments are relatively short
uh but we can use new technologies such
as targeted enrichment and high
throughput sequencing to get sort of
access to large genomic swallows of
information which we can then sort of
piece together an evolutionary history
of those particular pathogens of
interest
interestingly now um we have a question
from muddy here that says has there been
much research done on 8 on the ancient
dna of cholera it is not a disease often
talked about in paleopathology because
it seemingly does not result in skeletal
lesions yes it's a disease of the gut
isn't it right so you don't get in the
bone plus molecular research could have
a tremendous impact but is it feasible
that's for you hendrick
uh a very good question so
um uh that it's very interesting and we
have uh some work that will be out soon
regarding cholera i can't go into too
much detail about that uh needless to
say that it is impossible or at least in
in our hands to get vibrio uh the
bacteria responsible for cholera um
directly from skeletal remains for the
reasons that you just mentioned which is
that of course it's a pathogen of the uh
the intestinal lining um and therefore
it doesn't it's not systemic in the
sense that you'll find it in pulp like
we use for yesenia the black death um so
why you know even though we can't get it
from skeletal remains there are medical
uh tissues which do exist in collections
around the world that stem from these
early pandemics uh which occurred in the
early 1800s
uh
where there are remains of individuals
that that have died of cholera and they
that's one source of ancient cholera dna
the other one of course is as people
were buried with cholera the dna from
their guts likely leached out into the
surrounding sediment so it wouldn't
shock me that you would be able to find
cholera uh in the sediments surrounding
the individuals that were buried uh who
died from that right in fact hendrick i
think you're trying to do that aren't
you from body of potsevery where there
are bodies the working hypothesis is
that they died of cholera there are a
number of bodies buried under a lime
and i believe you gathered some dirt and
tell us what you're trying to do with
that
yeah so that that's exactly
that's exactly right and uh there there
is a site there at badia that uh
according to the archival records
suggest that these are indeed cholera
burials from the uh 1815 epidemic 1850
epidemic so this is the second part of
the second or third uh cholera pandemic
they're about seven or eight sort of
recorded uh in history um and we've what
we've done is we've sampled underneath
the lime layer in sort of the gut area
where we would expect the gut to have
been when the individual is interred uh
and we are
isolating total dna from the sediment
and trying to look specifically for
uh vibrio as long as along with other
pathogens as well using some of these
targeted enrichment uh and novel sort of
array screening methods
so you haven't obviously you haven't
published any of this yet so it's
unpublished work that you're working on
now right off the right off the press or
right off the lab
the dna sequencers and all that
tell me this um are you getting dna from
this from body of possibility are you
picking up dna from these bones from the
samples you brought back and from the
soil and places like that yeah so
there's definitely i mean the the the
good thing is that yes we get lots of
dna from the soil soylent uh
probably the more complicated and and
truthful answer to that is is a lot of
that not surprisingly are
uh bacteria that are
naturally living within the sediment so
so the challenge now becomes a
bioinformatic one how do we know that
the bacteria that we're looking at are
indeed uh endogenous to the individual
as opposed to the sediment now in the
case of vibrio it would be relatively
straightforward because you wouldn't
expect to find this particular pathogen
sitting in the sediment
of a burial site in italy
uh in the case of mycobacterium
something that we might get extremely
excited about and think well this is
tuberculosis we know that of course
sediment does contain a component of
mycobacterium naturally so it becomes
very difficult in that case uh to
actually
make a true identification without doing
a lot more work
that being said we have looked at some
of the sediment and there's some very
interesting things within the sediment
already there that's great so uh viewers
please keep typing in questions you type
them at the bottom of the page i have an
interesting question from sean that
follows on this let's take this from him
from
clark what safety and health precautions
must scientists take when at this site
you both have talked about tb
cholera as recently as maybe 150 years
ago um the plague the black death
possibly so can can the students working
there get these diseases yeah that
that's a question we we often get when
we're working on the site uh
when we're excavating these uh skeletons
and working literally right in the dirt
uh
people ask us well can you get these
diseases that you're you're hoping to
document through skeletal remains or
through ancient dna
and the long the the short story the
short answer to that question is no
that's very very unlikely that you will
pick up
any pathogen from one of these sites
there has to be very very special
circumstances preservation circumstances
and
fortunately for
99.9
of archaeological excavations those
circumstances are not present um
so
even though the soil may have a kind of
a smell to it um
it will
reading about in the article that you
wrote in um
it's it's safe i i don't recommend
eating the soil that's about the only
recommendation i would make
it's good news for us isn't hendrick our
daughters were both there helping to
excavate cholera victims or potential
color victims that's right well that's
why i sent her in first hand was to make
sure that
exactly send their kids in first see
what happens to them
so that was a question from sean we got
an interesting question from charlie m
and friends what about diseases like
cancer or alzheimer's were they
prevalent in earlier times or have we
evolved modern diseases based on
increased lifespan fast food diets and
sedentary lifestyle um either of you can
take that whoever you know maybe
maybe clark with a cancer and hendrick
feel free to join in on that one sure
yeah there there are there are cancers
and um i've seen a couple of individuals
in the body uh
series that possibly could be cancer uh
so
uh absolutely the the cancers that we
see today
uh are are present except the the
circumstances then and today are
different for example uh
in uh 12th century baudia they're not
smoking cigarettes and
tobacco in general
although some
so we won't see the kinds of cancers
associated with with smoking
but there are cancers we don't
understand that that are present in
archaeological populations during during
during these periods um so that brings
up the whole question of what's also
important about this work is
is understanding the circumstances the
environmental
behavioral
other factors that that cause these
diseases so
it's not that that hendrick and
uh giuseppe and myself are
interested in just documenting disease
we want to know what the circumstances
were so that's a that's a good question
that brings out that
that response
yeah no i think i think and to follow up
on that clark nand that it's important
to say that looking at the pathogens of
course is always only one side of the
story right so the human side is is
critical in understanding susceptibility
or protection for example so
why 50
or as it's quoted in the historical
documents of the european population
uh succumb to black death
might have something to do with the bug
likely has very much to do with
susceptibility in our genome
and then
in the environment played an important
factor as well as everything else that
that they were harboring at the time so
co-infecting pathogens as well so
um famine and so on and so forth so
really that i guess the point of this
particular site and the beauty of it is
that one can really study these entire
the entire context over sort of a
thousand-year period so not just the bug
not just the co-infecting pathogens not
just the microbiome but the genomes of
these individuals and potential
susceptibility alleles or protective
alleles that allowed the population to
move forward as opposed to
be stopped dead in the track so to speak
this leads to a question by rudy who
says by using a modern y pestis genome
to capture the ancient one
is it possible there were plasmids
present in the ancient strain that may
have had virulence genes but they they
disappeared in the modern so we missed
that while reconstructing the ancient
one it was a very it's a very good
question a very fair question a good
criticism of our first paper which was
basically we created a tremendous
ascertainment bias in our experiment we
said
well we don't really have any idea if
pestis is entirely responsible we would
like to get as much of the genome as
possible so we used a modern fully
annotated reference genome called co 92
which stands for colorado in 1992 which
happens to be the first sequence genome
from a a vet who died of a cat that
scratched him and he died and everybody
descended on this corvette and
eventually they sequenced the genome
that became known as colorado 1992.
and then
so we took that genome and we used all
small bits of it as probes to fish out
the ancient genome
um and so
he's right in the sense everybody's
right in the sense that that we could
have missed genes now there's two ways
we can deal with that one is what we've
done in in new work is gone back to
those original samples and we've
enriched using what we call a pan array
so we've taken all the known existing
soil dwelling pseudo-tuberculosis
yersinius strains as well as all the
modern yersinio strains and we've
created sort of a pan genome because
each of those strains actually have
different genomic content in them and
several unique regions so we said if if
we use this noun we target the ancient
one using this do we find novel regions
in pestis that exist in current strains
and we do we do find different things
that are present in some of the other
strains that aren't present in co 92
what i haven't addressed is are are
there strains uh not strains but genomic
constituents or plasmids that are
present in the old one that we have no
representatives uh today and we think
that there are and you can see that in
mapped regions actually
sort of as they fall off the end so to
speak so we can see sort of a three
prime end to a particular gene and a
five prime start and w we're missing
something uh in that case there are ways
to actually go in and pull those out
they require a lot of a lot of work uh
but i think they can be done so i i
think really the end to this is the end
of the story
uh my little soliloquy here is that
ultimately i think we'll be able to
reconstruct really what
uh the black death genome was for
example we should be able to do that
with other passages as well so you're
fishing for it with a composite genome
but you're also seeing sort of the
ghostly traces of some other
um uh plasmids out there some ancient
ones and then i gather you and some
other people like johannes krauss have
been going
uh to sites like body of pulsa very and
trying to get ancient dna from more
skeletons at different stages in these
epidemics is that right that's right and
so they're in the best of all worlds
you'll get a an infection that left such
a high constituent of bacterial dna or
viral dna that you can actually just use
shotguns so you don't need to use any
kind of targeted to capture you can
actually just straight sequence it and
then actually reconstruct the entire
organism without any of these holes as
was done with the case of leprosy and
something we're working on right now as
well
so in the best of all worlds you can
just use uh de novo assembly to sort of
stitch these ancient genomes together so
it is possible i never thought it would
be possible but it turns out that it
actually is
so what questions you might have it
sounds like too when you if you were to
get any plague dna
uh from body of pezza very or for some
other places where you're working um you
would be looking to see if there were
changes because i gather one of the big
questions is why if the dna sequence is
so similar in plague that's found in
rodents in the southwest today to the
black death plague that killed half of
europe in the in the 1300s
why if it's so similar was it so deadly
then or so virulent then but not today
so i guess you're looking for the clues
to that the answers to that question
sure well that's one thing yeah that
obviously one of the the interesting
questions with looking at ancient
diseases is to understand these
virulence factors um we don't have
epidemics or pandemics anything of the
sort today you don't have anything
that's killing 50 of the population i
mean if we compare the mortality rates
of 1918 flu which is sort of the last
great epidemic pandemic that probably
people in short-term you know memory uh
remember that was 50 million people but
a mortality rate of maybe three percent
the black death was on the order of 40
to 50 so nothing by comparison so we
don't really have
um
experiments so to speak human
experiments uh for obvious reasons where
we can actually study these changes and
so black death provides one possibility
and sites like body are are phenomenal
in that particular case in point um so
obviously are there small changes in
genes or in genes that
changes in regions that affect the
expression of genes that modulate the
virulence or the transmission rate or so
on and so forth and if we can if you
know obviously if we can target and
understand these uh that has
implications down the road for for
modern medicines as well
so clark we have a couple questions here
that are related um
peggy asks a question of whether you're
going to focus on specific areas of the
skeleton or the skeleton as a whole you
know are you looking in particular areas
and then she also asks how big is your
sample
yeah
we are really interested in
understanding the whole disease and
health experience so we're looking at
the entire skeleton teeth bone
top development
um
at this point we have a sample of
probably
uh
covering different time periods we're
looking here from early medieval
to 19th century
uh i would say we have 75 to 80
skeletons um this is a long-term project
we're looking at the next 10 years i'm
hoping
we all live that long and
so i i foresee as having
hundreds of individuals it's a large
series of skeletons surrounding the
church
so small at this point
but enough to get it started
and what let's tell me why this is
important to do why do why do
paleopathologists what is the
significance of studying
the evolution of health and disease over
a thousand years what would this why
would we want to do this today what
could it help us with yeah that that's a
great question why why is this important
um
what one thing is
that that uh
that
modern diseases uh infectious chronic
the conditions we see today
i didn't get there by magic there's a
whole history of of health
of precursors of current diseases and
part of our job a big part of our job is
to document that record of health and
tracking that that history of health uh
and
leading to
leading to current conditions i'm
involved in a long-term large project
looking at the history of health in
europe based on a
skeletal series of about 17 000
skeletons it's a large cooperative
effort with
european biological anthropologists
americans and canadians and
we're documenting health changes from
about
uh 5 000 years ago to the present
and a big part of the story takes place
during the middle medieval period um
and that record shows that these
conditions of osteoarthritis bone
infection oral health
that we see today has a clear record in
the in the past and we're able to
document the changes that began uh the
largest samples we have began at about
2000 years ago
but big peaks and decline in health
during the medieval period
that's important to know because
again it provides a context for what we
see in today's populations
and i i think that's crucial in
understanding how today is that record
of the past
hendrick what about you what's the value
of looking at the evolution or the
origins of something like the plague or
cholera tv
um
well i mean obviously as an evolutionary
biologist you're interested in in the
question of evolution period how things
change over time
um
obviously there are things that we
mentioned just a second ago about
looking at small changes in the pathogen
that may have contributed to effects of
transmission or virulence and those
themselves can be very interesting
certainly in the case of cholera there
may be things that can help for
medicines today i mean one thing that i
think we seem to overlook though
is why not just know about the health of
these individuals in the past these are
our ancestors to some degree so why
can't we just be happy in the knowledge
of understanding the human condition we
are human we are interested in our past
um so rather than always having a
medical relevance i think it's important
to know that just understanding that is
important to
who we are as individuals today
um
obviously not only looking at the
individual then if we go back to the
genetics is looking at the how these
pathogens have modulated our genome
right i mean
with that kind of mortality rate in the
medieval period you had a huge
bottleneck probably one of the greatest
bottlenecks certainly in recent times
tell people what a bottleneck is yeah
yeah so when you when you go through a
bottleneck you reduce uh the genetic
constituent and diversity in a
population by
it can be a small amount a large amount
so for example in the case of the black
death we wiped out in europe on the
order of forty fifty percent of the
population so we reduced the diversity
by half right so if the black death was
responsible for that there must be
selective remnants of that event in our
genomes today certainly those who have
uh european ancestry and so
understanding
understanding that and really studying
that is i think is critical because
looking at selection the human genome is
very interesting for
various reasons
and it's very hard to do from
contemporary populations to try to date
those events in the past so if you can
study them in real time
that that has tremendous value i think
it's interesting to think that all that
europeans today are all the descendants
of the survivors of the plague and was
there you know are there is there do we
have any protective genes or
you know it must have affected us to
some degree and and sort of
understanding what those you know what
the selection units were on and was it
just luck or you know there's lots of
anecdotal stories in the historical
records about people that lived on farms
that seem to be immune and this idea
that if you live near horses because
horses don't get fleas and so there's
all sorts of these environmental things
as well but if we can really study both
the pathogen at least and the human in
this case
um
and it may not be may you know maybe
it's not the pathogen maybe it was just
the burden uh the pathogen burden load
that the the particular set of
individuals had those living in
concentrated urban sites were much far
more susceptible than those living and
maybe more or
open
worlds sites so
lots of questions to address really yeah
yeah it's fascinating
and we also get a sense clark you uh
alluded to this how difficult their
lives were it's so interesting when you
say that in the medieval ages that they
that health really declined and tell me
now how body of pots of area might fit
in that by
looking at trends and health over time
in one place can you start to get a
sense of how things like a battle that
played out next to the to the church or
famine or other hard events that you
know about in time changes in climate
might have impacted health are you
interested in looking at those kinds of
questions get
yeah um it's uh
yeah health is uh is very multi-factor
we're we're looking at uh
all the conditions that would influence
the health profile for each period of
time ed badia
you mentioned several of these we're
look we're looking at
our
work there during the 14th century
endemic warfare various points in time
that of course
affects productivity crop productivity
availability of food uh
we're looking at climate instability uh
during uh during various periods of time
the little ice age is going on here
between uh 1300 and
the later
later 1700s
and so what what does that climate
instability do do to the
how does that influence health profiles
so
what what we've engaged in here is a
focus on one little place in italy
but with
answers to multiple questions about what
what causes health
stabilization improvement decline
and it says multiple lines of evidence
looking at climate looking at warfare
looking at
social conditions
these are highly stratified sites or the
the people on the top
nobles
and upper clergy are seeing access to
better resources than
uh peasants
and so that's another complicating
factor as well who
who has the better conditions at this
place and at different points in time so
it sounds on the surface a simple story
we're looking just at this one locality
uh
but digging deeper it's a it's a complex
story and then placing abadia in the
larger picture of europe
and are there trends that we see at this
one locality that match the general
pattern of europe and those are those
are unanswered questions
we
uh there has not been an interest in
medieval bioarchaeology for example uh
uh much of the interest uh study of
ancient skeletons is much earlier in
time so
our work on the medieval period that
for some of our colleagues uh that's a
that's a sleeper but uh
in terms of a very dynamic period of
time
uh badi is going to going to give us one
of the best chances to get a profile of
the conditions and circumstances that
affect health
so
as hedman pointed out part of the story
is understanding
uh
modern conditions and how that's going
to contribute to understanding modern
health
but but
but just as importantly is
understanding the the human condition
that long profile that long period of
time
in this one place in europe in general
why were things so bad in the medieval
era you mentioned the little ice age
starting after that why what are the
working hypotheses about why it got so
difficult and stature went down and oral
health got worse and disease
increased well there are a number of
things going on for example population
size is increasing in general
and so as population size increases um
there that demands an increased
productivity and that increased
productivity is coming from
crops and crop production
i think that that what's sneaking place
we don't know this for certain yet but i
think this is how it's going to play out
is that increase in focus on
carbohydrates and lower quality foods i
think that is a is a big factor
i think the climate instability uh
where some ears are very cold some very
warm i created conditions where there's
uncertainty in that crop production
so that's another factor and uh another
point being with that increased
population size
is
just increasing those circumstances that
will
provide a context for the spread of
infectious disease uh sanitation
conditions uh
they're living on the on the side of a
lake uh that's no longer present but
that provided perfect circumstances for
uh for malaria
uh and uh
in this particular setting so
it's it's complicated but we believe we
can sort out those variables that that
we just talked about here
there is an interesting anecdote in this
particular site where there was a battle
and and the florentine troops camped
right next to the church and they
complained they were sick they got sick
while they were there in the historical
records and they complained about the
ball aria the the bad air
and uh it almost hints that maybe one
reason the florentine troops even though
they are much larger than the troops
from luca there are many more num in
number
uh one reason they may have lost to the
luca forces in this famous battle of
aldepasio is that the troops got sick
when they can't have body parts
that's right that no doubt uh malaria
was highly prevalent there
no doubt many of those soldiers died
from
from disease
and the circumstances of living closely
together like that
could not have been healthy so uh and
plus a
they lingered there for quite a long
time and so i think that by the by the
time the battle develops um
they're they're greatly reduced in their
effectiveness as a as a fighting element
it's so interesting how disease shapes
history so
as much as anything else and then
hendrix so that battle of aposia which
all school children in italy know about
and study is the most important battles
um in 1325 that happened and then soon
after 1348 right the plague comes in
early in 1348 into tuscany coming from
the port towns what i wanted to ask you
is this population had been growing up
until that time in tuscany spread of
people this was a pilgrimage route going
by
um
after the plague
things get better for the survivors
because the population was widowed there
were more opportunities what's your
sense of how that might affect
the
trajectory of well i mean i guess it
depended on who you really were if you
were a landowner it probably wasn't very
good but if you were looking for work
then it was and you know it certainly
seems in the records that people could
demand higher wages because there were
fewer people to do the jobs so it
created a social unrest that uh
was unparalleled before i think
according to what the historical
documents seem to indicate so uh and
that that was probably a good thing in
the sense that it normalized uh
conditions for some people to some
degree because there was this tremendous
hierarchy the feudal society so any kind
of benefit for the worker during that
time was probably a good thing
but as we know that that you know the
plague stuck around for many centuries
in europe and kept striking
uh repeatedly over time both through
tuscany and and we even know that some
of the later epidemics in the 1600s
actually had mortality rates of 60 and
70 so even higher than some uh claimed
during the black death time period um
so it what it was you know you had
moments that were peaceful probably but
but it eventually came back and then and
it disappeared which of course is sort
of an open question as to why you don't
find your senior pestis uh present at
all in europe today anymore
clark we have a question from from terry
it's and he asks what is the proportion
of diseases that does not leave a trace
in bones how global can a view be that
analyzes only the fraction of diseases
that left a trace in bones
do you feel like you're getting a handle
on most of the disease or yeah that's a
that's a that's a good question we we
know there are diseases that don't
affect them there are acute
pathogens uh where
the individuals die quickly and we're
going to have no record of it however
that said it's not just disease we're
looking at we're looking at
elements of growth disruption that we
see in teeth we're looking at
microscopic
growth disruption
we can see
macroscopic growth disruption in teeth
we see elements of reduced stature
we see uh growth and development
problems in general so
what we're getting at here
is not just a record of this disease and
even and we're looking at the larger
picture of help
that said if we just looked at disease i
think we would have a pretty good
picture of what quality of life was like
uh based on historical records and based
on the skeletons so
fair enough there are some diseases that
we don't we don't capture but i think
uh
based on my experience with with doing
doing this work i think we have a
representative picture of what health
was like
and it seems too that sometimes you see
multiple diseases in one individual so
you see what i guess you know a burden
some of these people are carrying
several things at once and was that the
norm in the skeletons you look at i mean
were people plagued with more disease
more problems in the past
by comparison yeah i i think in general
that is true that in the past what we
see are individuals with
uh
oftentimes multiple infections growth
disruption taking place at the same time
i in various factors combined all all in
one skeleton um
so i i
yeah the the health burden is complex uh
it's usually not one thing it's multiple
factors
how about you hendrick what do you see
when you look at your dna samples when
you look at one individual do you
see generally more than one thing um
well that's still sort of we're still at
the testing phases of those kind of
things obviously we would assume like
clark mentioned that there are multiple
things infecting an individual um and of
course we know that a lot of the
bacteria that we live symbiotically with
uh can become sort of pathogenic uh if
we're under sort of immune
compromisation and the other bacteria
sort of taking over
um and so i think i think dna really has
a tremendous potential that way because
it you know as long as there's a
signature of the molecular signature
still
uh in the bone or or maybe not so much
the bone but the teeth uh then i think
we have a good possibility in detecting
it certainly as these methods get
increasingly strong in terms of the
depth of detection now that being said
we still have a lot of bioinformatics to
go through to be able to really identify
uh you know at what point how many sort
of molecular signatures do we need
to be able to actually say
uh without hesitation that this
individual had the following
four or five particular
infectious agents present in it and then
you have the the other question which of
course did that individual die from
these things or did they actually manage
to live through them and so on and so
forth so
um i think that's the the beauty of this
particular site the beauty of the
collaboration is that we'll be able to
look at all these things sort of in
unison together so like clark mentioned
is a long term project where we don't
just look at a particular flash and fan
we're going to look sort of over deep
time uh
in this particular area which has you
know migration routes which suffered
from all these climatic variabil uh you
know variations and variabilities and
war and famine um so we can really get
both a dna picture a human health
picture from the morphological
characteristics uh the human genome
aspects as well uh really to get a very
good complete deep uh idea on human
health and what sort of drives
infectious disease and human biological
diversity really
we have an interesting question here
from uh judy she asked given that this
is a pilgrimage route okay so what we
need to say is this is one of you could
explain that um do you anticipate being
able to distinguish the deceased as to
country of origin and maybe i should
rephrase that a bit i don't know if you
want to say country of origin but are
you going to be able to get a sense of
ethnic diversity or um
you know the range of peoples that went
along this pilgrimage group by this
church
or the diversity is that something you
can detect do you think and get a sense
of
yeah i'll log i'll start this out
one thing we're interested in is is uh
who who's who's buried in this church
yard are they are they
completely local is it is it just from
that that locality are they are some of
them pilgrims um
who who is this population i think
probably what we're going to find
is that it is primarily local in terms
of who's buried there but i will not be
surprised if we um
if we if we find individuals who
are from elsewhere who don't fit the
particular genetic profile
and by genetic i'm looking at this in
terms of both
work that
that hendrick
and colleagues will will work on in
terms of ancient dna
but also looking at at biological
distance and and ethnicity
by a phenotype that is a particular
characteristic of the skeleton and teeth
that reflect uh genetic context
so
um again i think that that most of these
people are for our local but given that
it is a major pilgrimage site that
extends the it's a it's a route that
extends extends from rome
all the way to canterbury and it's very
heavily trafficked uh
and still today there are individuals
who are walking the the pilgrimage that
we see while we're actuating the site
so no doubt some stopped maybe some
stopped because they were ill
and decide to stay if they if they lived
long enough so
so uh that that's an important part of
the story is is what what effect of
or well how important does that program
is root in terms of determining who's
who's buried there who who's who's in
that cemetery
will you be able to detect the
gap-toothed wife and the other uh
characters of chaucer's canterbury tales
on their pilgrimage
kendrick you're gonna answer that too
well i know i think i think it's an
important question um you know there are
ways one can do it even using stable
isotopic signatures of strontium oxygen
just find out whether or not people that
are indeed buried there were born and
raised there whether or not they
actually came from further afield
before they settled down in that
particular area and then of course the
genetic signatures give us some
indication of
possible geographic origins um
pinpointing those to a particular uh
very specific area is sort of very hard
to do without having contextual data
from that time period that we can make
sense of right now trying to base
um
the geography of an individual
in the medieval period just based on
sort of haplotypic frequencies today's
is always a bit problematic nevertheless
i think that's the beauty again of this
site is we can sort of get an idea of of
diversity
and haplotypic diversity uh genetic
diversity over this entire time frame
and so that might give us a better idea
along with the isotopic and
morphological characteristics of whether
or not we're looking at a sort of a
constant slow turning over population at
the particular site or we're actually
looking at different points in time for
a lot of input of diversity coming from
different regions so i think yeah that
certainly adds interest uh to the
the case and and the study that we we
want to carry out here certainly if you
have particular diseases coming in at
particular points in time where you do
see increased diversity or or not uh so
yeah no there's so many interesting
things about the site and what we can
actually do it's really it'll be an
interesting several years
this pilgrimage route is i guess
theoretically
one of the ways in which the diseases
were were spread more rapidly as people
moved up up these routes soldiers
crusaders uh pilgrims all different
people coming to and fro these were the
routes by which many diseases moved as
well it wasn't just people well sure
yeah i mean it's two things right it's
the the individuals who are moving
themselves quite quickly and of course
it's the pathogen which may have changed
uh in terms of its dissemination so you
in the case of
the black death you know we don't really
understand why it moved so quickly
across europe infecting so many areas if
it was a bubonic sort of flea rat human
model and so it makes much more sense
that it probably became a mnemonic form
and spread by by malaria in bad air in
the sense of you know coughing and
sneezing and so on and so forth so there
are two things you're looking at is the
migration of the individuals and then of
course the pathogen physiology biology
itself as well
very interesting we we have a question
here um
to what extent can paleopathopathic
proof to what extent are our paleo
paleopathologists able to distinguish
between susceptibility to disease from
previous previous exposure do you pick
up on that and from
genetic inheritance the ability i guess
to withstand the disease or
the actual having it so can you say that
just one more time you sort of fade out
for a snack i think basically the
question is are you able to distinguish
between somebody
having some immune reaction to the
disease but not getting because they've
been exposed to it before do you see
that kind of response
uh compared to actually evidence of
having a disease i mean well yeah i mean
very interesting question you know some
people claim that you you you know
antibodies themselves should be
uh preserved within some of these
remains so maybe it would be possible to
find antibodies for a particular
pathogen actually still present and of
course that would be fascinating because
that's one of the reasons people think
actually you know the greater mortality
the plague had nothing to do with by you
know the pathogen or the humans
themselves that just had to do with you
know that typically when new pathogens
come to a naive population there's huge
mortality rates and so that might be the
simplest explanation um i don't you know
i haven't done any kind of that that
sort of scanning or screening for
antibiotic
antibodies left over but it could very
well be that you know some people do
indeed have immunity from previous uh
infections
um whether or not there's epigenetic
markers which of course is something we
haven't talked about yet but of course
is becoming sort of the mo du schwa in
ancient dna now which is you know these
extra methyl uh groups that sit on the
outside of your genome which involve uh
modulated expression
um of your genes
you know they are left in cases of great
insult so it could very well be that we
can start scanning these ancient genomes
for methylation patterns which may be an
indication of past infectious uh
diseases which would be something very
very interesting so basically looking at
the stress burden from an epigenetic
perspective on these uh individuals in
the medieval time periods
right
i'm just going to add to that is looking
at the stress burden
factor there as well as is documenting
how early the stress is in life
we know that that early stress prenatal
early child
early childhood
will predispose the individual to an
earlier adult death usually due to some
chronic condition
that is
younger stress
results in
chronic conditions like heart disease
diabetes and so forth so
part of the story here is looking at the
at the temporal context within the
within the individual um
and that's part of our our future
research here
that's interesting
um and it leads to a question that um in
fact rachel rachel rochelle asks are
there any commonalities in the type of
pathologies you're finding on the
skeletal sample so far
and
i would add to that
clark commonalities at different you
know in the past and how they compare
with what we see today when you talk
about diabetes and stress we have quite
a bit of it in our population now
at a younger and younger age so it's
interesting are you seeing any
commonalities i know this is early days
for body of folks to vary but i guess
i'm asking in the global health project
and trends in europe
are there commonalities in the
pathologies you're finding in the
skeletal sample other than you know you
talked about the medieval period being
tough
um
yeah i would say that that probably the
most common pattern throughout the whole
sequence that
we of course have a pretty small sample
size at this point but i
predict that we will see
throughout the entire
occupation of badea
is a is a high prevalence of
osteoarthritis i think that's that's
going to be very prevalent through the
whole period
uh the records show from early medieval
to through the 19th century into the
20th century
uh very heavy labor very heavy activity
uh mobility uh
agrarian related activities uh in
agricultural production so i think we're
going to see what i showed early on in
our in our program here
that kind of osteoarthritis
and debilitating osteoarthritis as well
and what about compared other trends
these people often didn't live as long
as we did so you might see a different
pattern of diseases um are there other
trends like that that are different
today
right so very different from these
people i guess
there one one difference between the
sample in general that we'll see at
bandia and today
is the fact that people live longer
today than in the past and so
some of these chronic conditions which
develop late in life
or become more prevalent in life
will be less frequent in the badea
series from early to late um so uh that
that is a factor that that how long a
person lives and their exposure to
pathogens and factors that lead to
disease so very important question and
one area that we're looking at a
follow-up question from laura mckinnon
is how are you recording what you find
so that as new and improved technologies
come along they can be applied to what
you are unearthing at this important
site
also a good question we we're using new
technologies at every level of the
research uh
from excavation to study um
one of the technologies we're using is
recording burials it's so important
a lot of folks don't realize that
that much of the labor that goes into
this project is just gut busting field
work it's very difficult
and it's it's hot it's it's uh difficult
digging these holes believe me uh
and at the same time though we we have
to the point being we have to record
everything very very carefully it's not
just bones drug out of a pit but rather
they are exposed they take weeks to
expose
we expose the bones and use new
technology to
record what we're finding and that is um
we're using a practice of photographing
the burial
and recording the
the points in the photographs with
geographic information systems where we
can document very closely very carefully
the location of bones the burials
uh accompaniments to the skeletons
and uh that's a that is a new technology
that's that's developed in the last few
years
um and then in terms of the study the
skeletons were using
uh some of the things we've mentioned
here today uh stable isotope ratios to
document a dietary change stabilized
operations to identify
uh
potential migration patterns potential
origins of individual people
we're using
scanning electron microscopy to document
patterns of tooth use
it turns out that virtually anything you
eat will leave a record on the surface
of the tooth and hard foods leave
different records in soft foods
and with this technology we're able to
document very clearly
what kinds of foods the tooth use
patterns they're using their teeth also
as a tool
and so
that scanning electron microscopy is
very helpful in documenting those sorts
of things so
the the record of technology is just
booming
in this field
and we're taking every advantage of what
what uh what technology is developing
so we're getting down to the last
question here and let's just follow up
on that and though yeah go ahead that's
fine just because i think it's important
to mention that that there are ways that
the dna crowd the ancient dna crowd can
certainly contribute to that long-term
storage as well which is to say that
when we take extracts out of teeth or
sediment or bones now we actually add
little linkers onto the ends of them and
they become what we call a library so to
speak and those linkers we now know
because they're synthetic molecules that
we add to the ends and those linkers can
then themselves be targets of
amplification
so basically a library per se from a
bone or a tooth can be amplified in
perpetuity over and over and over
and then that library can be actually
dead dry down into a a non-condensing
desiccation tolerant
format and then stored long term either
back at bodia back at the university
with clark here in the lab that don't
have to necessarily be stored in the
freezer they can be stored dry and so as
bioinformatic tools or ancient dna tools
get better it's possible to go back to
those extracts from those bones uh and
actually sequence deeper or do de novo
assembly uh using better parameters that
were done during my time so to speak and
so i think that's important to mention
that those should be then freely
available for other people to look at to
use when they're targeting a particular
bug or a human gene of interest for
example so we're down to the last couple
minutes that's really interesting and it
would be interesting to be able to
compare
trends at one site as as the global
history of health project does
through other sites from the last same
time in different places just to begin
to put together a composite picture of
what the patterns are in health and
disease and stature and diet and you
know all those things that you guys are
looking at i think the very last
question when we're down to two minutes
is we have one from sean asking since
there's there is now lots of buzz about
gut flora and the immune system with
these remains provide any insights in
how into how the immune system has
evolved in the past thousand years as
well very interesting question
i guess sandra go ahead yeah no sure
absolutely i mean it's a great case to
be able to do it i mean certainly the
black death is is a very i would say
easier uh
case in point because of course you can
look at populations prior to the black
death of course from you know we have
collections of those you can look at
those that succumb to the black death
from these mass burial pits and of
course then the population thereafter so
you really actually can study
genes that we know have played some role
caspases matte k genes that have played
some role in the immune system
and look at how they've been modulated
by disease now if we look at body of
course we can do that on a very finer
scale there as well see how those
frequencies of alleles within those
genes have changed uh over a thousand
years at a particular site and then
combine that with what we know about the
geography of the individuals and the
local whether or not they're local
whether they've been migrated in from
other places and so on and so forth so
really as clark pointed out this is a
long-term study it's not a quick fix
um and that's the beauty of the site is
is both the space but the depth and that
really provides us with a window into
the past and i think that can catapult
to our understanding of human biological
diversity today
that's great and and clark there was a
question from someone saying how do you
ever allow the public or students to
come help you excavate clark if you
address that then more after that yeah
we that much of the excavation project
was a field school um
and i
it's a it's a great one because there
are there are a number of experts on
site uh there's a great staff that
supports the field school
um
and so that's a possibility we we
don't take volunteers um
uh there are some individuals who are
members of the project or who are uh
paid on the project but mostly the focus
of it most of the people on the project
uh in terms of students are
field school students
that's great well i want to thank our
viewers who asked really great questions
i want to thank you clark for uh
wonderful answers and hendrick too and
for letting us take your time tons of
your time for this and to tell the
viewers there is a story that's been
posted today on science's website all
about the sighted body of pensavari
there's an interactive story that has
lots of details and video of these guys
working there and photos and and lots of
description of the science going on
there so take a look and thank you so
very much
thank you thanks claire thanks i'm
cedric thanks ann
thanks take care okay cheers